when should the guy get married before  or after getting his career on track i  think it totally depends on who you meet  you don't want to meet the girl of your  dreams and then think well i have to get  my career on track and i know there are  a lot of red pill people out there that  are like just wait wait till your  mid-thirties get your career on track  make all your money then hook up with a  23 year old they're most fertile at 23.  marrying somebody and getting that  relationship  organized in your life  can  excel your career right if you have  someone there to help you that can  actually  help your work life i work with my  husband so it's a bit different but  being in a stable relationship with  somebody who's who helps me  has made me 10 times more productive and  i've made him more productive so i think  if you find the right person it can help  excel your career so i wouldn't put off  marriage